amsterdam's most famous product
carefully weighed and packaged the
city's 166 coffee shops selling cannabis
are a worldwide attraction research has
shown that 60
of tourists come specifically to visit
one of them
and that includes international artists
and celebrities
mike tyson a long time ago and even
dennis hopper
back in the day and they all got stoned
here
they all got stoned in the greenhouse
and and
they had a really good time in amsterdam
but they're not allowed to come in the
future anymore
no so that's going to be very difficult
if if
snoop dogg or richard branson are coming
here and then you have to
refuse them entry to limit illegal trade
in drugs the netherlands opened its
first coffee shop in the early 1970s
where a small amount of cannabis could
be bought and consumed
this unique service quickly attracted
customers
we are very proud of the system that
we've had for 40 years and and the whole
system basically is based on the fact
that everybody is welcome
and everybody can come to the coffee
shop and
buy their cannabis in a safe way the old
city center of amsterdam is usually
packed with thousands of tourists and
the smell of cannabis is never far away
since the lockdown this is how the dutch
capital looks like
local residents say they can finally
sleep to them this shows that tourism
was out of control olaf ulrich has lived
in the old city center for 40 years
together with other residents he started
a campaign to make the city less noisy
and more livable
it's a kind of a silly idea that people
who smoke pot don't
do any harm or so of course if you're
five young people
from france or belgium or wherever you
come from
in a car and you're excited to go to
amsterdam you buy your pot
you buy your six pack of beer in the
supermarket and you go
hang around or whatever and do whatever
you like coffee shop owners and
customers blame
alcohol consumption rather than cannabis
for the nuisance cost
and they believe the mayor's move to ban
foreigners will lead to more
illegal street trade there are other
ways of getting it and i feel like
that's what people gonna gonna try to do
right
because as i said amsterdam is more than
just just smoking
but it is it is part of it definitely
important part
important part as well yeah yeah
absolutely if i can say that
the mayor says this does not mean she
wants to change the image of amsterdam
as a city known for its freedoms
we don't want to be that city where
masses of young irish and london youth
come to get drunk and stoned during
their holiday
that is not the kind of freedom we want
international fame for
we want to be famous for our freedom of
conscience the mayor hopes that by
imposing more restrictions there'll be
less coffee shops so it will be easier
to legalize
them because while it's legal to buy
cannabis here
there are no regulations in the
netherlands for those who supply it
step fast in al jazeera amsterdam